[Aplausos]
un lunes hace dos años me levanté con un
dolor de cabeza en la parte izquierda de
mi cabeza creí que era una de esas
migrañas que estoy acostumbrada a tener
desde mis 10 años bueno como todo el
lunes me levanté cansada para ir al
colegio
y para mi sorpresa mi primero de clases
si no era de mis materias favoritas
matemáticas para la cual me considero
pésima como de costumbre la maestra nos
pidió que hagamos unos problemas
sumamente fáciles
claro para ella
no sé cómo pero yo lo logré y lo
entregue primero pero después de eso
note algo extraño en mi cuerpo mis manos
temblaban
hoy tengo algo que me gustaría
preguntarles a todos ustedes pero
primero quisiera que ustedes me
respondan algo a mí alguna vez lo han
sentido este dolor de cabeza por una
carga absurda de deberes y trabajos el
dolor de estómago antes de dar una
prueba el temblor de voz y manos al
hablar frente a un público al recibir un
mensaje al entregar un simple trabajo
importante pues yo así y esta es mi
ansiedad y no hablo de una ansiedad
patológica hablo de una ansiedad en la
que yo siento que estoy en una gran
montaña rusa en la cual no quiero estar
y de la cual no me puedo bajar
sé que la ansiedad se puede mostrar en
diferentes personas de varias maneras en
mi caso es un dolor de espalda
acompañado con un dolor de hombros
migrañas y tal vez el temblor de voz y
manos que alguno de ustedes hayan podido
notar
bueno desde mis 3 años comencé a
adentrarme en este maravilloso mundo de
la danza y antes que nada de contarles
mi historia me gustaría decirles dos
cosas importantes que yo encontré en el
recorrido de mi vida
la primera es saber que no soy la única
persona que se ha sentido así y no lo
seré y la segunda y me valgo de citar a
nietzsche al decir esto es que la vida
sin música sería un error y mi música es
mi danza
desde los 3 años como ya les dije
comencé a bailar baile ballet salsa
flamenco danza folklórica hasta llegar
al día de hoy presentarme a ustedes con
la danza milenaria del vientre
exactamente no hay antecedentes precisos
para esto pero si dice que comenzó en el
año 1200 antes de cristo y lo que más me
llama la atención de esta danza es que
se ha mantenido hasta ahora es
trascendente por eso aquí lleva a
asociar la coreografía con la vida con
el público es algo así como que nuestra
coreografía la presentamos frente a un
público y ese mismo público puede ser la
ansiedad esa ciudad de la que he venido
hablando esa ciudad que me han mentido
de pequeña desde que voy a llegar a
sexto curso y voy a saber qué carrera
escoger a qué universidad e ir que la
economía del país va a mejorar entre
tantas otras cosas que ya sabemos
es por eso que siempre trato de mantener
en mi mente a aquellas mujeres que
empezaron con esta danza como ellas iban
tan sencillas con el cabello suelto pies
descalzos y una simple tela alrededor de
su cadera y esta tela que fue
evolucionando con el tiempo desde como
aquellas mujeres recogían las monedas y
se las borda van como símbolo de su
ganancia es lo que asocio con nuestros
triunfos que vamos teniendo en la vida y
es así como nosotros y asumo que todos
ustedes quieren tener sus triunfos para
toda la vida
es muy importante saber que la vida y el
arte no solo es
una batalla diaria es mucho más que esto
llantos miedos gritos y es aquí donde
los gritos creo que son muy importantes
porque gritar a veces significa
desestresarse el sag haré dos a gary era
un grito originariamente conocido como
un grito de guerra
para mí este grito significa mucho más
es expresar nuestros sentimientos de
alegría pena temores
es suerte y éxito un saludo y a veces es
una despedida
[Música]
sí
así
todos
[Música]
bueno como acabaron de ver
como einstein decía nosotros somos los
bailarines de nuestros propios sueños
miedos de esperanzas somos los propios
creadores de nuestra vida
hace algún tiempo ya una persona me
había dicho
camila turismo entera tuve hambre si no
es caro o algo por el estilo y bueno que
quisiera que mi vida fuera como esas
coreografías de broadway que vemos o
gris o el mismo high school music o no
es así y no es tan fácil ya que todas
esas geografías llevan un tiempo un
proceso arduo y tortuoso lleno de
lágrimas sudor y miedos
cuando yo comencé a bailar me meta la
verdad era poder mover las caderas como
shakira
y la verdad es que no fue tan fácil y no
lo será por el simple hecho de que debes
de aprender a disociar tu cuerpo mover
el torso sin la cadera mantener los
brazos de arriba o el simple hecho de
sonreír y bailar era algo que yo no
podía hacer
hoy yo no les puedo decir que si nunca
más volverá a sentir ansiedad ni miedo
porque es imposible siempre había una
persona una circunstancia un simple
mensaje que te haga sentir amor tristeza
miedo estrés ansiedad
esta ciudad es algo que yo encontré en
mi camino de la danza árabe y la tomé
como mi amiga
ya que me daba ese impulso eléctrico al
seguir yendo a mis clases aún así me
diera vergüenza
y me di cuenta que el bailarín nunca va
a ser vulnerable frente a un público que
no conoce su coreografía yo hace algún
tiempo puede que me haya equivocado
varias veces no sé tal vez algunos los
notaron otros no pero seguí y lo único
que puedo decirles es que he decidido
seguir bailando frente al público que se
me parezca
y así como yo encontré mi arte espero
que ustedes encuentren la suya ya sea en
el canto en el baile en la poesía en el
dibujo
y así como yo encontré mi arte les
pregunto a ustedes que están esperando
para encontrar su arte y seguir con su
movimiento gratis